Every year I promise myself that I'm gonna be organised for Christmas
before December rolls around
and every single year I get to about this point in the month
and I realise that I haven't even started.
I'm shopping for two preteen boys and a six year old girl
and let's be honest
six year old girl's gonna be happy with whatever I buy for her
but preteen boys however is a much more difficult age.
Ha ha, not just for presents.
In my family
you wake up and there's a stocking on the foot of your bed
and you're allowed to open it before your parents wake up
and that is how I get a little bit of extra sleep on Christmas
and the perfect stocking always starts with an orange in the toe.
Don't ask me why
it's just what my parents did for me and it's what I do for my kids
and I like to put things in there that are interactive and fun
and will keep them occupied for a little bit longer
but they need to be small enough to fit in the stocking
and good enough quality
that they're not just gonna break or end up in the bin
but also not too expensive
because when you times everything by 3 kids
so with that in mind
I went to the warehouse yesterday to see what I could find
and I actually found some really great stuff
and before we get to that
This is your friendly reminder that Christmas is about presents,
not presents.
There have been many years where I've absolutely had to scrape
together something for Christmas
for my kids. They don't even remember what they got.
Do you know what I mean? They remember being with you.
They remember sharing food with you.
They remember laughter and time spent.
So please don't financially stress yourself this Christmas.
Have fun and just be there for your family.
With that said, this is what I found.
Everyone's getting a whoopee cushion.
I know it's not the world's greatest gift,
but a little while ago
my daughter got one at a birthday party and everybody loved it
and it broke and she was very sad.
So they're getting one each.
Everyone's getting a small Lego.
Oliver is getting the Lego friends.
We already have a few from this range and she really likes it
and it has a dolphin and I know she will enjoy that.
And I got two Harry Potter Legos.
I feel like everybody's gonna want Aragog cause it's sick.
The flying car is pretty awesome.
It also has Hedwig and scabbers
and I made sure that both of these came with Harry and Ron.
If you were to ask me what I'm personally most excited about
at the moment, I think it's these Nido squishies.
They look like goody goody gumdrops.
They come in a range of different colours.
They look like this and when you squish them,
oh, My word,
they are just so satisfying.
Everybody got a book.
This one is definitely not gonna fit in a stocking,
so I might need to rethink how exactly this is gonna work.
But I knew I had to get this
because my son has been wanting to read The Hunger Games for so long
and I've never seen an illustrated version
and the illustration was just phenomenal,
even for the golden limit.
Apparently it's like the Davinci Code for kids
and my little girl loves the Dragon Girl series.
I thought a little game for everybody
in their stockings would be a really good idea.
I thought for my oldest son I would do UNO Shono mercy.
He's probably the most competitive player out of all of us
and apparently this one's like the cutthroat version of UNO.
For my middle child,
I thought that this Super Mario matching game would be cool
and I got a squishmallows Trumps game for olive.
No idea how to play, but she loves squishmallows.
So everybody in my house loves to draw.
I think it's a great activity and they always go through sketchbooks.
Whoa! But I feel like finding a good sketchbook can be kind of tricky.
These are A4 plain sketchbooks,
really nice card stock, like quite thick paper, $5.
My boys are super into anime and manga,
manga drawing styles.
So these are some fine line pens that I picked up for them
and the little girl, a little Bit more playful,
some calligraphy pens I thought I'd get everyone a T-shirt as well
cause they take up a good amount of space
and they're actually not that expensive
this cute little number $5
my eldest is about to turn 13
and he is at a very difficult age to buy for
because he knows what he likes and he knows what's not cool
and I don't know what's cool.
Apparently we don't wear things like Minecraft and Pokemon anymore
we wear cool things so I'm really hoping he likes this.
I thought it was super cool.
We saw one like this recently
which was hideously expensive and I found this for $10
and my other son is 10
and he still very much likes wearing gaming things
so Sonic the Hedgehog I got some popping elves
which I will just check a few of these in the stocking.
We had a Bop it,
we had an R2D2 Bop it and it was great and so fun and so competitive
but it broke and so I was trying to find something similar
I could only find two
I don't know what I'm gonna do about the third one
just a classic bop it and Simon says
I also picked up these little interactive pets
and I was thinking for olive and for my niece and nephew
that these would be really cute
she loves taking care of things.
Do you know what I mean? So that's a little ducky Turtle and a lizard.
Another little cheap and cheerful gift that I saw were these Crayola
scribble scrubbies. Inside the pack is a pet
and there's all these different kinds that you can choose from
and a couple of pins and you can colour in the pit and decorate it.
And then when you're ready
you can clean it and then just do it again and again.
For my six year old, I was like,
she will love this. Like I said,
she will love anything for Goldie because of course
we can't forget the fur babies.
She's got a tube of tennis balls
and I'll probably get her a rope toy as well
and maybe something from the butcher to chew on
because that is all that Goldie needs to be happy.
But it is Christmas for the pets as well.
Wrapping paper. I bought this whole pack because I like the gingham.
It was six bucks for three.
So $2 each, absolute bargain.
And gold gingham because I just thought that that was so cute.
And I checked the docket and I paid $9 for two of them.
So they must be 4:50 each.
I'm such a mum because
the final thing that I got when I was there
was two new laundry baskets
because I don't know if you've ever seen my laundry basket.
They're pretty old and pretty beat up
and one of them has a massive crack in them.
So I got two new laundry Baskets,
$15 each and they are sturdy.
Like that is some thick plastic.
Now I feel like I can relax
because I actually have a start on Christmas.
Everything that you've just seen came from the warehouse.
They've got great deals on everyday dog races.
I had so much fun shopping there yesterday
and I was very impressed by the range.
They had heaps of things in there.
And I've taken a few photos of other things that I wanna come back for.
But now I better go hide this quickly
before somebody walks in and spoils Christmas. Love you.